every year thousands of people had to
like search for the wave gothic festival
the city hosts concerts and parties for
fans of the goth scene but many go to
just show off their style and that
doesn't always mean black
first of all I'm a Hello Kitty soldier
because yeah I liked Hello Kitty and
second of all I'm a cyber fairy in a
neon bubble steampunk there are
steampunk clothes and steampunk items
gifted fans sometimes spend hundreds of
euros on costumes like on opulent
Victorian wigs clothes and extravagant
hats and you can see them all here at
the festival's tradeshow Spanish
designer BBN Blue has her own stand
there she specializes in corsets and
lace dresses I think that the fashion is
there one of the main important thing of
the of this gothic scene apart from the
music it's a fashion it's always been
like that
it's like pangoro it's like so many
different styles away we need to
reinvent all the time and we need to get
inspiration from everywhere gothic
aesthetics have recently been adopted by
well-known brands who have produced
collections inspired by the dark designs
the new face of the fashion label
eve-san Lahaul isn't a model but Marilyn
Manson one of the world's most famous
Goths the festival has been going on
since 1992 back then a few hundred
people came together to listen to Gothic
music this year 20,000 attended music is
still a big draw for the event this year
more than 200 bands are playing this was
Celtic group kal and Rome is one of them
as is the folk rock band Leicester
instance
the band dusk has been here right from
the start their big names in the goth
scene and playing clubs all over the
world
the combat slider there are people from
porto alegre in brazil who save up for
three or four years to be here every
year they put their christmas money to
one side so you can imagine what the
atmosphere is like here in this
metropolis this gotham city
people come face to face with the
capital of the gothic see their shots
and seen as it's done to its love for
the dark side that fuels the fire of
bands like american rockers Evanescence
they're mysterious but catchy tunes have
topped charts right around the globe
with their vicious vocals heavy riffs
and nightmarish costumes German shock
rockers Rammstein also take their fair
share of cues from the Gothic realm
Alexander Newman is fascinated by it
the cultural scientist used to be a goth
himself now he's writing a book about
how the scene has changed
there's a kind of quit Who am I it's not
a subculture anymore in the 1980s there
were just a couple of kids into it who
went around with funny haircuts and
strange makeup in order to shock people
they probably never dreamed that 25 or
30 years later such a massive event like
this would be organized and billed as a
cultural festival
well those first guards have grown up
into raising families the young and old
still meet here from cyber Gods to fans
of the medieval to baroque booties the
event is also listed in the city's own
cultural calendar and tourist guide
books and for people in life stations
it's certainly an eye-catcher
hoopskirts are fantastic the Rococo
stuff I really like it there's some
really striking people like that guy
with a mask okay it'd take some getting
used to
lovely corsets they're great today even
foreigners are coming the gods tendency
to shock has diminished but the style is
still intriguing placed as it is with a
sense of aesthetic in addition to being
mildly morbid
you